من يناير من وقت ما تم الاعلان عن الصفقه
التاريخيه بين نادي النصر السعودي والنجم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو والانبار
والاخبار
كيف تصدر خبر انضمام رونالدو لنادي النصر
الصحف العربيه والاجنبيه نصر نادي كبير
معروف محليا واقليميا واسيويا وانضمام نجم
عالمي بحجم رونالدو جذب الانظار لو من حول
العالم اكثر واكثر ومن وقت ما حط رونالدو
رجله في السعوديه وجماهير النصر من حول
العالم بتزيد يوم بعد يوم هذا غير محبين
النجم الا بداوا يتابعوا حسابات النادي
واليوم عدد متابعي النادي على انستغرام
اكثر من 13 مليون متابع وعلى حسابهم على
تويتر اربعه مليون متابع اما على فيسبوك
في عدد المتابعين لحساب النادي اكثر من
مليونين متابع وعلى يوتيوب اكثر من نصف
مليون مشترك ويبدو انه تاثير رونالدو على
اداء النادي على منصات التواصل صار واضح
كثير ونشر موقع اسمه فوتبول مختص
باحصائيات كره القدم احصائيه بتعكس تاثير
انضمام رونالدو على النصر من ناحيه
الارتفاع الكبير في اعداد المتابعين الجدد
على النادي اللي تربع على عرش قائمه افضل
النوادي اداء على المنصات واحتل النصر
المركز الاول في جذب المتابعين الجدد خلال
الشهرين الماضيين باكثر من 9 مليون متابع
جديد خلينا نشوف مين باقي الانديه اللي
جاءت في قائمه فوتبول
[موسيقى]